she wouldn't stop crying so I was like
I'm gay that is Lance Bass revealing
that he came out to Britney Spears on
her wedding night oh not that one yeah
that one
okay let's rewind during the stop by
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
the 40 year old NSYNC member revealed
that he came out to Britt in January
2004 immediately after her Las Vegas
wedding to Jason Alexander it was the
night that she got married the first
time
yeah and Jason allegation yeah okay so I
went up to Vegas to uh you know kind of
see the craziness that was happening um
and she was a little upset once she
realized what she had done and he was
you know it was a funny thing and then
she started like really crying and like
she was so upset of course we all know
how that marriage ended with an
annulment just days later but before
that Lance was right there to console
his friend look at her room and we're
sit on the bed and I was like and she
wouldn't stop crying so I was like I'm
gay cuz you tried to give her sang and
it made her stop crying was she sweet
and supportive chuckles yeah right
Lance says that Britney was one of the
first people that he came out to his
confession occurred about two years
before he came out publicly
but Lance's revelation isn't the only
reason Brits making headlines on Monday
she made her red carpet debut with
boyfriend Sam ash Gauri at the premiere
of Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
Britt looked fab in a sexy red one strap
dress by Nikki with black heels and a
silver choker you better work [ __ ] well
Sam looked dapper in a cream-colored
suit white shirt and dark tie but it was
the diamond Britt was sporting on that
finger that has everyone talking and
wondering are these two engaged a source
previously told et quote Sam is really
in love with Brittany he's her protector
the source added that one of the things
Brittany loves most about her man is how
great he is with her kids with ex Kevin
Federline 13-year old Shawn and 12
year-old Jaden quote her kids love when
Sam is around they have from the
beginning of the relationship he gets
along with all of them very well
et has reached out to Britney's camp to
get to the bottom of that new bling and
you can count on us to be the first ones
to let you know if these two lovebirds
are getting ready to walk down the aisle
so make sure to keep it locked right
here on e t until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]